hello and welcome to this video playing
Alex here with white and see how he's
doing Knight f6 know what is wrapped
twice in detail here's a teammate of
mine so I ready so a little bit
surprising don't see that too often from
her but okay black does not have to take
but night XD for is a decent pre move
here now at bd7 you can't play that but
it's not as good as this when 96 is a a
decent way you have to play it okay so
cam ticking ticking is not very
promising but 96 escutia check so you
don't see it too often check
yeah here black probably has equalized
this line would be three is something
that I've played a lot over the years
it's it's fairly safe and have won quite
a substantial number of games Adam if
black like here i'll place it correctly
it's quite difficult to to get something
get something going let's do this not
quite sure here I of course I want to
try a little bit not just shuffle around
and make a draw there are some lines
here that are really not good for black
at all and this is as I said is a pretty
good one so the worst is definitely over
fam it sounds too strong yeah it's not
like it's not terrible for black anyway
but there are some pretty comfortable
lines and here black is quite ok I think
huh that looks a little bit passive
really ok mag away for
the Sun am Bishop a three sometimes
Bishop f3 and Bishop before I actually
quite a good set up against the head
shock it's not seeing that often but
it's not so bad see what he does this
one yeah some p5 is what he wants to do
i can double up on the deef porn maybe i
can just double up yeah still I can do
this 198 and e5 is pretty strong I
thought I'd take I'm going to win an
exchange at least I am threatening to
take on the six which would kill black
instantly so he basically has to give me
the exchange I believe with gtx e5 or d5
no evidence also looks bad
Wow then I'd rather given up the
exchange of a black ok so 94 like a four
actually is good just shooting for might
be six what's prevented ok so I Group C
1 and now is he threatening to check on
these sex no I would need I would need a
knight knight on d5 office I that's a
funny funny position and I'll just go to
go to the eighth or something
[Music]
it just looks so nice and I don't see a
an immediate win night b2c 45 again
would be would be cool but yeah if I
play night beach we might take on d6
with the night so I think I probably
should do this look to be seven
[Music]
yeah and definitely to you five would be
good so let's do this check so night b2c
fryer that should be should do the trick
I'm probably playing the the slowest
possible way could have probably killed
this off more than once foxy 7s
should promote the poor black resigned
okay thankfully i'm back over 2,300 okay
so let's have a look today I am um yeah
I think that this is a good line for
black against my setup I think black has
excellent chance to equalise the way it
went things would all that easier thank
you for be five now by the engine okay I
wanted to play like that but probably
this now 496 and this was a good one
yeah he okay night if for seems to be
interesting with doubling up I think
also felt quite nice we could to see
eight well computer just gives us up I
mean this is this is this year
definitely was wrong after your 5 i'm
winning so group DC aj that's a strong
move it seems now and he gets this back
nice yeah here this is this is a pretty
pretty clear win i think i probably the
too far too long killing the soft but i
think it was never in danger so it's
probably okay okay i did not see 95 here
actually sew wins but huh and here the
the comp rewards ok guys thanks for
watching